♪ ♪ ♪
- Une ville refuge pour
les Ukrainiens déplacés.
♪ ♪ ♪
Lviv est accueillante...
... mais peut difficilementfair.
♪ ♪ ♪
Oleksii, 19 ans, s'est réfugié
ici avec ses proches, dans cet
endroit qu'il connaît à p...
Le jour où il a quitté sa maison
d'Irpin, en banlieue de Kiev,
restera à jamais gravé
dansmomomomoire.
Sa grand-mère et lui ont fui
en catastrophe, dans la voiture
d'un ami, pour échapper
aux  bombes et aux tirs russes
qui s'abattaient sur la ville.
Sur la route, ils ont découv
l'horreur : les carcasses
de quatre voitures calcinées,
des familles, qui les
précédaient de quelques
kilomètres, bombardées.
"Des gens qui tentaient,
comme nous, de fuir une ville
à moitié détruite.
Il y avait des bombes,
ils avaient peur et voulaient
se sauver. Mais la terreur
ne s'arrête pas là.
(Il imite le son
d'un projectile.)
Une roue de leur véhicule
a été touchée par un projectile.
Effrayés, ils ont roulé un pneu
à plat, sans s'arrêter, jusqu'à
un endroit sécuritaire.
"Je voulais seulement
rester en vie", dit-il.
Quand il parle des Russes,
Oleksii a peu de mots.
"Ils devraient tous payer."
Même s'il est maintenant
en sécurité, les mauvaiseselele.
Il y a quelques jours
il a reçu des photos
de la maison familiale...
... complètement détruite
dans un bombardement.isisisisisn
l'intention de retourner à Irpin
pour rebâtir leur foyer
et leur quartier.
"Nous voulons aider les g
à retourner y vivre."
♪ ♪ ♪
Un projet, un espoir auquel
s'accrocher, impatient,
comme tant d'Ukrainien
de rentrer à la maison.
Ici Louis Blouin,
Radio-Canada, Lvi